l'autre quels sont tes mensurations
quelle est ta taille 1 m 68 et demi quel
est le poids 68 kg moi je ne suis jamais
monté sur les skis mais c'est de leur
apprendre comment ça sert à quoi
mais ça sert à glisser là ça alors ça
c'est pour ces la fixation pour mettre
les billets de banque
voilà ce qui doit le most par le gauche
ou par la droite en avant l'importance
là on est sur le plat alors on met le
bout du pied quand m me voilà donc et on
appuie et on appuie thermique à lui j'ai
mis mon habit du dimanche pour conduire
l'accord yonne yonne
jacques auriau ça ça sert en cas où le
ski partir et ça me retiens non car le
ski
brad pitt appel c'est
voilà moi tu t'appelles anne philipe
hellip et ben tu connais claude latta
jamais vu une fois la crise
tamuz aux banques l'eau la gloire par
rapport à gm sur h on explique on vient
te demander les autres grave c'est
sympathique ça compte pour toi oui
j'aime voir d'importants oui je pense
les artistes importants
koné combien de disques maintenant j'ai
4 45 tours et troyes 30 cm je prépare le
quatrième 30 centimères mon grand père
c'est un sacré chasseurs un chasseur
invertébrés poète chasseurs première
chose avoir une bonne vue avoir une vue
perçante une vue perçante ça mon grand
père il était servi et il avait la vue
tellement personnes que pour patrouiller
le journal il fallait qu'ils fermaient
un oeil les clair qu'on l'appelait mon
grand père il se promenait jamais sans
son fusil
on a vu un veste mystère 12 cartouches
dans le magasin d autres dans la
cartouche hier il y avait un truc il
faisait ses cartouches lui même
dans la première il mettait des plans
dans la deuxième d'apu d'éternuer
pas loupé avec les plans y renvoyer un
coup de coude à éternuer
c'est bien le gars il gît bien s'en faut
mais pas sur une souche emprunt
des fois c'est lui qui ce sommet sur la
crosse du fusil la poudre y en avait
pour tout le monde une fois attend que
je tends cause comme je vous dis mon
grand père y promener dans la forêt tout
est bien évident une passe et en forêt
qu'est ce qui débouche deux ans lui seul
donne en mille un cendrier mais un
sanglier
attention la bête pas n'importe quel
sanglier un sanglier 12 qu'aux membres à
faire pas surpris par son fusil il
épaule et vie utile le coup part pas
innocent viii et broutin peut y reposent
erwin et dire le coup bah oui l'humidité
sûrement est pas sans vie à l'art vers
il garde dans le canon et huanuco qui
ment pas samedi avait fini de beauté
j'ai marié était comme un enfant deux
enfants de son âge
quel âge as-tu philippe 12 13 ans à ba
tu vois j'ai une fille qui a 14 ans et
un garçon qui ronge henry blick
[Applaudissements]
- claude j'ai l'impression que la forme
physique est quand même important bien
sûr si on se prépare physiquement c'est
le muscle son frère des progrès sont
forcément plus rapide mais c'est si rare
et c'est important d'un sport qui est
quand même mobilisé certains groupes de
muscles et
les muses de coop répondre à cette
mobilisation par les passants un petit
peu en arrière du kehrweg pour éviter de
coûteuses
[Musique]
aïe
claude j'habite dans un chalet qui
domine gérardmer qui s'appelle la grande
lourd
est ce que ça veut dire la grande lourd
et bien les lourds c'était les veillées
dans le temps arrivée les grandes y
avait les petits tirent tout vers chez
toi ya de grandes veillées de grandes
lourd mais parce que dans les grandes
lourd on mange et on danse et ensuite on
allait reconduire les filles hors jeu
préféré que ça s'appelle la grande lourd
plutôt que la petite ligue aux tirs
conduit encore les filles ah mon dieu
oui des fois il faut parce que quand il
ya de la neige et le risque de se perdre
le risque de vous on n'hésite pas on
leur donne tout de suite à un coup de
main c'est comme ça on va les laisser se
perdre dans la forêt a laissé manger par
le dard ou est ce que tu sais comme tu
es chez toi tout seul tu bookeen et là
c'est pas beaucoup le temps parce que je
suis pris par le courrier j'ai pris par
un tas de choses puis je suis quand même
souvent partie ah non là week-end chez
jamais là un pari bah oui ça sera
difficile
d'accord un se note pour le 3-1 et ben
merci monsieur jeux rien ne va
il est parmi mon espèce de pigalle ah
bon bah ouais mon beau fils a reçu moi
je peux pas m'empêcher de rire je peux
pas m'empêcher de faire rire c'est dans
le centre les clair que je te dis on a
une autre fois à temps que cinq autres
comme je vous le dis mon grand père il
était parti en forêt faire du bois comme
on dit chez nous dans l'hérault et puis
à midi mais faut casser la croûte qui
comprend alors il fait son feu et puis
monsieur patate dans la braise pour les
chercheurs et un b ils n'étaient pas
installés prêt à casser la croûte
je te le donne en mille un vol d'oies
sauvages qui passe à mon grand père est
dit c'est pas possible peut pas laisser
passer une occasion pareille
il sert son fusil pour une fois elle
n'avait pas on dit c'est pas possible de
laisser passer une occasion pareille
comme outil naveix h au foirail
il l'a fait tourner ikb est il temps
mais vrai la ballarat le troupeau d'oies
ça tombait sa tombe et il avait un tas
doit comme ça mais retrouver plus h
[Rires]
il va aimer une femme arrachement pour
continuer mon boulot et après mais les
huîtres y retrouve toujours pas là faut
il n'y a pas de problème jugement à
commencer par un bout il par les oies au
fur et à mesure et les plumes les soins
d'un côté les plumes de l'eau il
retrouvait toujours pas sa hache au i l
ne peut être que sous les plumes il met
le feu au plus sachons fait face au fait
face aux fesses avaient tellement
chauffé claras avait fondu il n'a pu
prouver que le manche
comme le hall b si tu avais le temps de
lire qu'est ce que tu dirais les
histoires drôles ou quelque chose à
l'origine par j'aime bien ce qui est
j'aime bien les choses qui font rire
c'est quand ma détente mois ci rire
parce que je fait tellement rire les
autres souvent moi j'aime bien rire un
peu moi même alors je lis des trucs
marrants mais à force de faire rire les
autres ce que tu ne te sens pas
quelquefois peu victime n'a personne à
des obligations de ferries oui oui au
fait c'est normal c'est normal
à partir du moment où on campe un
personnage
le public vous voit sous l'angle de ce
personnage on est obligé de 2,2
j'étais amie quel est le défaut que tu
regrettes le plus j'aime pas qu'il soit
envahissant si tu jouer d'un instrument
quel serait-il j'aime beaucoup la
guitare
tpour l'ordre ou pour le désordre ben
moi j'ai un désordre ordonné
c'est à dire que là je fiche mais à
faire n'importe comment mais je les
retrouve et tu croyants non alors
pourquoi dis-tu de ta maison qu'elle est
celle du bon dieu
elle est celle du bon dieu parce que le
bon dieu c'est au sens large du terme
pour moi le bon dieu c'est c'est la vie
c'est la terre c'est le soleil ces
étoiles c'est tout ça et je pense qu'il
faut accueillir
les amis accueillir même ceux qui ne
sont pas mimer qu'ils vont devenir
mam est votre ma maison est ouverte
parce que l'hospitalité pour moi c'est
une chose qui se perd c'est bien dommage
et en ce qui me concerne je crois avoir
le sens de l'hospitalité
quel est celui que tu considères comme
le meilleur amuseurs devos
je ne sais pas si vous avez été en
vacances l'été dernier vous avez été en
vacances l'été dernier n'avait pas eu
trop de bouchons or les moussons et vous
ouais pour une fois que j'allais à
l'accord je suis bien réchauffé j'étais
en vacances voulait aller dans le midi à
la soierie vais tout de suite d' al
mehdi lalmi dit gérardmer 11 km que j'ai
fait j'ai pas pu aller plus loin à cause
d'un bouchon un tout petit bouchon
pourtant le bouchon d'huile au l'a
jamais retrouvée on était parti à
bonheur pour pas avoir de boussole
l'aquaparc de temps pays je roulais
intime à tout d'un coup j'entends le
bruit s'arrête
genre tu es mort le bruit des morts je
me rare est le bruit fera ray j ai pas
tout ça nous suit
[Rires]
keith hawton en panne qu'est ce qu'on
fait on soulève le capot mais la main
dans l'abri d'almaty latin je mets la
main dans un blender
non c'est parce que vous croyez
c'est pas faut te raconte m parmi sa
poule s écouler je vais chercher le
mécanicien mieux nous en effet du propre
d'année pour huit jours lui joue puis
jours au tholy et vous en avez fait du
bruit jouvet du faucon reste toujours un
petit truc comme ça depuis le temps
qu'on commun des pièces qu'elle revienne
quand les renvoie pas ce que c'est par
les bandes les jours au tholy vos paris
c'est un peu comme les parisiens qui ne
connaissent pas la tour eiffel
alors on en a profité pour visiter la
fromagerie
on a demandé notre chemin à personne on
ya été oh
au pif remarquez on n'a fait que passer
comme les trois films jours à faire la
voiture était refaite alors la 1ère
partie le succès ça grise ça risque
grise et bien sûr il faut faut garder
les pieds sur terre
à moment donné base environ une file de
voitures en aurait marre est derrière le
dernier ce qui fait le dernier c'était
pluie c'était pas moi non plus ne vint
qui me suivaient ceux qui étaient devant
moi baisse sa vitre mbi c'est le bouchon
déboucher d'ici ses débouchés pourquoi
quand passe par une bille nord les
bouchers coin les marchands myard qui
rouspètent contre la hausse des prix
on va voir fait et dit les bouchers
rouspétait ils distribuaient de la
viande à tout le monde
quand je suis arrivée elle n'avait plus
de la découpe et il voulait m'en donner
sur pied une vache entier une vache
cinquième set je vais mettre ma femme
même dit le boucher himdi une femme
d'arv une auto ça ne sert à rien lundi
ce qu'une vache ça court
après brest mais boucher vous faites des
10 ne peut pas durer comme ça on hausse
les prix en hausse le filet hausse
l'entrecôte hausse les épaules en hausse
la culotte mais sans tout ça via celui
qui est à côté de moi souvent nous avant
qui nous coupe les brandt l es tu
sensible à la musique militaire et marc
je déteste pas mais faut pas que ça dure
longtemps
puis pas forcément le jour du défilé
mais je ne déteste pas ça c'est un
disque de de pastorale roumaine c'est un
instrument qui ressemble un peu à la
clarinette s'appelle salle à tarragone
j'aime bien c'est du voyage beaucoup tu
étais en roumanie et non et non je
voyage très très lentement parce que
j'ai pas tellement le temps c'est sûr
mais même si j'avais le temps je ne sais
pas si je voyagerai beaucoup suivant
gien des racines qui s'agrippent ici
pourquoi qu'on irait ailleurs on est si
bien ici on se pète parce que dans
entendant du mauvais temps parce qu'il
pleut un peu plus souvent dans l'est
puis enfourner bien quand même
il enfile fatigue du sport est ce que là
tu es combatif agressif est ce que tu
veux gagner en est obligé objets dans un
slalom en ski et par exemple si on se
bat pas avec les éléments et les piquets
avec avec c'est ce qui est tout tout
tout ce qui à la pente les bosses les
dévers les déséquilibres si on se bat
pas c'est pas la peine de prendre le
départ en voilant régate c'est la même
chose si on se bat pas avec le vent avec
le bateau est ce que tu es
collectionneurs non pourquoi je suis
collectionneur à la façon des vosges et
en général c'est à dire que je garde un
morceau de ficelle je garde un cloud car
d'une vie sans me disant ça peut servir
je mets ça dans un coin dans une boîte
et bigorre et besoin je le retrouve plus
alors je vais acheter ce qui me fout à
la quincaillerie voilà c'est à peu près
ce qu'est ce que l'ex par contre j'aime
bien les choses vraies choses de
une racine qui me sens sans la modifier
comme elle est un caillou pas parce
qu'il a de la valeur mais parce qu'il a
une belle gueule parce que c'est un beau
caillou soul comme ça mais j'en fais pas
c'est pas mon dada pour toi est ce que
le monde finalement est bien ou mal
c'est moi je suis content moi je suis
bien je vis dans un monde actuellement
je n'aurais pas voulu vivre à une autre
époque je suis content comme ça
as-tu la télévision non pourquoi
c'est difficile à dire pourquoi parce
que d'une part on n'a pas beaucoup le
temps de regarder si j'avais la
télévision personnellement je n'avais
pas tellement temps de regarder ensuite
mes enfants la regarderai souvent plus
que moi et il ne regarderai peut-être
trop donc je suis pas souvent là pour
doser si vous voulez les programmes ni
perdre être autant de toiles post on
arrivait ou condamnés à dakar parce que
- n'étaient pas là je vous l'avais
toujours ben hamidi mais quand c'est
arrivé nous restait plus qu'un jour je
vais passer les jours sur la route
or gt gt la paix choix histoire de me
tremper le bouchon mais la mer va l'être
je mens tu nous parce que c'était pas le
tout de rigoler j'allais au travail oit
a aussi prévenu ma femme j'ai prévenu
mes gosses leur ai dit vous avez inséré
à votre info n'est pas ce qu'on ne
s'arrêtera pas prenez vos dispositions
nous avons mis un matin bonheur
[Musique]
là j'exagère à peine
c'était plutôt du genre à temps on sort
du villa on sort du village un
attroupement dit ça y est ça recommence
ibo à la route y en a qui s'amène avec
un gros panier
je bosse marie nbc tu devines ce que
j'ai dans mon panier tu en auras une
grappe du raid
vous avez gagné 30 kg de raisin offert
par les marchands de l'est du coin gît
sa tombe tous bien nous quand vous les
paléo restera aux mains nues
une grappe de 0 2 à 3 2 je ne sais pas
si vous avez déjà mangé du raisin toute
la journée du réseau rien du raisin un
moment donné où on à la cocotte-minute
la cocotte minute qui fif
les gosses derrière par part est ouest à
venir je passe haut et passe temps de
m'occuper des affaires courantes
ma femme à côté je t'en prie ou un opus
tiendrais monsieur arrêter comme ça m'a
pris aussi alors l'ont laissé la voiture
ou encore prouvé
on courait dans les champs dans l'état
idriss elba
on étalait nova quand tu prépares tu es
salade de pissenlits
tu vas me faire la cuisine j'aime bien
rire j'aime bien mais la petite cuisine
avec du truc
une omelette au lard pour ton percepteur
officiellement tué maîtres d'éducation
physique
c'est le principal de thé revenus mais
maintenant ton nom tient la fiche dans
le monde du spectacle de variétés et
l'heure du choix peut se poser là dessus
j'ai déjà pensé à ça mais pour un tas de
raisons je pense pas quitter l'un pour
l'autre parce que j'ai besoin du sport
j'ai besoin du contact des jeunes des
jeunes j'aime bien me retrouver dans six
dans le week end je vais faire un dégâts
la semaine des as et épuisante c'est
pénible travail de nuit
mais le lundi j'arrive pas que saïfi
obligé d'être là d'être frais d'être
avec mes jeunes d'être sur les pistes ou
sur mon bateau en vol et ça c'est
nécessaire pour l' équilibre d'accord
c'était 7 à l'échelon régional et
supposons que une bonne fée vosgienne de
pétrone vis-à-vis qu'ils ont de bruno
coquatrix pour donner un nom et que tu
es la chance de pouvoir démarrer à paris
quelle serait ta réaction
ben ce moment là bien sûr on faudrait
remettre ça en question mais où j'irai
vraiment pour le gros truc là la grosse
chose par exemple si on me propose de
faire du cabaret à paris passer tous les
soirs dans un cabaret je dis non
mais si on propose de faire un passage à
l'inter bien sûr disque on a
connaissance
ce qui n'empêchera pas de garder quant à
kate mon métier je veux pas dire pour ça
que je vivrai à paris parce que ça ça
m'intéresserait pas tellement alors ma
dernière question sera celle ci est une
sage je pense
le ch'ti ya longtemps qu'on connaisse à
nous autres on à vannes en a fait avant
vos du ski mais sans a bien changé oui
d'abord maintenant izimmo pour s'amuser
à ce qu'ils nous on y allait pour
travailler ouais jusque vers 19 sept
on avait des raquettes pour aller en
forêt mais fera pas que des étrangers
viennent faire une démonstration de
sauts sur ce qui s'était réellement
rappelle guerre c'était énorme les
géants allemands
vite les normes et j'aime pas ça c'était
des skieurs avec leurs culottes de cuir
le jour là y'a nokia même sauter jusqu'à
saisi m
alors après après moi j'ai eu délit si
des jeux marneffe aider ce qui est plus
grave et plus large du
des plus beaux pour qu'ils portent dans
la profondeur mais il avait fait trop
long la fois là parce que là pour
prendre les virages c'est de la route de
la bresse falaise et poires manos à
l'écart mais pas si c'était pas des skis
comme le jour d'aujourd'hui qu'est ce
qui a impliqué mastic et puis on n'avait
pas de charnier de sécurité et puis il y
en avait pas de chaussures qu'on peut
pas marcher avec
[Musique]
celle de nathalie chaussures qui font
d'eux chausse pied pour intraitable
j'ai raté mon qu'une fois
[Musique]
c'est enfin les outils tu passe la nuit
avec les choses et les demoiselles qui
viennent fait du style ça serait pas
plutôt l'après ski on aimerait bien par
chez nous quand on rénove sauterelles on
voit bien le socket faut dire qu'elles
sont pas toutes comme ça il y en a qui
font du ski ou qui a ravi d'apprendre à
l'eau alors elles prennent un moniteur
jeunes
alors alors qu'elles font exprès de
tomber alors le moniteur et les relais
et puis elle retombe dit il mais ray
dans quels ressorts et harmonie de mai
de skis haut comme dirait monsieur curie
s'est cantonné sur l'amour et sparte
quand sa vie s'est il n'y a même pas
donné leur tête
et puis le coulage le coup là que
j'étais dernier petit sapin y en avait
une qui
moi je voyais bien
je parle plus pékin voyez bien qu'elle
n'était pas là pour faire du ski
comme disait madame r vaut mieux ça
qu'une jambe car c'est le ski c'est plus
ce que c'était moi je vous le dit
[Musique]